Hello.
Google Cloud Load
Balancing enables
you to scale your applications
from zero to full-throttle,
with no pre-warming needed.
You can distribute your
load-balanced compute resources
in a single or multiple
regions close to your users
and meet your high
availability requirements.
Cloud Load Balancing
puts your resources
behind a single
anycast IP and allows
you to scale your
resources up and down
with intelligent Autoscaling.
Cloud Load Balancing can support
HTTP, HTTPS, TCP, and UDP.
We are excited to introduce
a new Load Balancing
UI that enables you to configure
any of these flavors of load
balancing intuitively and easily
through a single interface.
With the new UI, you
simply pick the protocol,
configure the related
parameters, and you're done.
In order to create a
new HTTP load balancer,
click Create Load Balancer.
Now click Start Configuration
in the HTTP/HTTPS Load Balancing
section.
Fill in the name of
your load balancer.
You can use lowercase
letters, numbers, and hyphens.
Click Backend
Configuration to configure
where your incoming
traffic will be redirected.
From the drop-down
menu, you can select
an existing backend
service or you can
create a new backend service.
Now enter the name for
your backend service.
From the Backend section,
select an instance group.
Finally, select a health
check from the drop-down
at the bottom.
Your backends are
now configured.
The next step is
to determine how
your traffic will be directed.
Click Host and Path Rules
from the left panel.
The first row determines where
any traffic not explicitly
with a host and path
rule will be sent.
Click Add Host and Path
Rule to add a second row.
Now fill it in.
The third step is
configuring your frontend.
Click Frontend Configuration
to configure the protocol,
IP address, port, and
certificate, if necessary.
Once that is done, you can
click Review and Finalize
to review your configuration.
Finally, click the Create button
to create your load balancer.
When the new load
balancer is created,
you can click its row to
expand it and see its details.
If you want to modify
its configuration,
click the Edit button.
You can go through the
same steps you went through
during load balancer creation.
Backend configuration,
host and path rules,
and frontend configuration.
Finally, click the
Update button if you
want to apply your
changes or click
Cancel to discard your changes.
In order to create a
new TCP load balancer,
click Create Load Balancer.
Now click the Start
Configuration button in the TCP
Load Balancing section.
Fill in the name of
your load balancer.
You can use lowercase
letters, numbers, and hyphens.
Now, click Backend
Configuration to configure
where your incoming
traffic will be redirected.
Select the region where your
instance group is located.
Select an instance
group you want to use.
Select a health check
from the drop-down menu.
Click Frontend
Configuration to configure
the IP address and port.
Click Add Frontend IP and
Port and enter a port number.
Now you can click
Review and Finalize
to review your configuration.
Finally, click the Create
button to create your TCP load
balancer.
When the new load
balancer is created,
you can click its row to
expand it and see its details.
You can use the Edit button
to modify the configuration.
You can similarly configure
UDP load balancer, as well.
To view all your load
balancers, go to Networking
and click on Load Balancing.
Once you've configured
your load balancers,
you can view them and also
view their details, as well.
We invite you to give
the new Load Balancing
UI a spin at cloud.google.com.